I've decided to tell you my life story
it all starts
right to Rich's story about this kid in
the streets of Acapulco and how he got
to be this billionaire right now I'm a
pool boy but one day I'm gonna own this
place I love the confidence I felt that
we needed a show you can watch and go to
sleep with a smile on your face or
solely for the soul that's Acapulco
[Music]
during this second season all the
characters are evolving
now that the characters are established
we can really dive into what those
relationships are like and expand the
world we've set up
we have a new love interest on the show
Isabelle she has no idea about the
connection I had with Maximo in season
one
now that he's going back to his Origins
we're gonna see a different maximum back
then he was another person he left also
a lot of things pending
Maximo okay that's the second time I see
you hiding for me today that's not what
I was doing
season two has been even more fun than
season one because we all know each
other now we are more free to try new
tones we play more with the Rhythm and
pace of the scenes in 36 years as a
professional actress it is not common to
find these Sensations that we have I
like to believe that Las Colinas is not
a place or a destination it's a
community the fact that we're shooting
here in Mexico it's important to me I
want the series to reflect how beautiful
it is and especially the people
foreign
[Music]